so Justin we went to sweet Double Fine
event last night and they were showing
off some games that actually are going
to be unveiled at pax this year they
showed off a costume quest and massive
chalice and a bunch of Double Fine
presents games so would you think about
everything there were no surprises these
were all things that had been announced
previously but things that I'm excited
about nonetheless I'm actually wearing
one of my double find adventure shirts
which maybe is the best thing to wear to
something like this but I'm a big
supporter of double fight in the games
they do on the backer of massive chalice
and as soon as they talked about costume
quest I was totally on board like having
a sequel to one of what was for me a
really highly anticipated super fun
super cute game I was 100% on board just
as soon as they said costume quest to
yeah they've been talking about this for
a while now and they've been super
excited about saying you know it's going
to be what everyone loves more costume
quest now they're not mixing it up too
much but they've made some updates to it
one of the big things is new costumes
Darren's pretty psyched about I feel
like there's not really a whole lot that
you have to do to change I mean there
was it not a perfect game by any stretch
but it was really solid for what it was
and and the only thing that you know
you'd really want more out of our
different costumes and different ways to
play the game and so some of the cooler
things we got to play with we're a
pterodactyl which is it that's a
ridiculous costume in itself and you're
just like flying dinosaur and we got to
every costume has an attack in like a
special attack that's pretty easy to
build up but otherwise the combat itself
is very similar to something like super
mario RPG they but the costumes
themselves are a whole lot of fun i
think now they have thomas jefferson as
a character there's a superhero and they
also have gender changes free time I
heard that so now you can actually
before in the first game you if you were
a robot you were just robot where is now
you can be a female robot or you could
be a dood robot they're really opening
it up for your imagination
cool thing that they added was before
you needed a particular costume to be
able to jet around and now any costume
can jet so now you can kind of scale the
map much more quickly and efficiently
it's only thing that I was a little bit
worried about before before I actually
got to play it was what the story is
going to be about because and costume
quest to is just about you know saving
Halloween howdy how do you go back to
this and grummons on ice was left a
little bit of a on a cliffhanger this
time there's a an evil dentist who's
coming around trying to steal the
world's candy and you know get rid of
Halloween and it leads you into this
polka post-apocalyptic world where there
is no Halloween and everything is
horrible and you have to go back in time
to save Halloween and get rid of the
dentist minions and spread candy to the
children of the world it's really a pure
story because everyone hates dentists
and now we can just kind of combine
together and take them down and without
candy there would be nothing but a
post-apocalyptic world another thing
that was at the Double Fine event was
massive chalice which people have been
really kind of hyped about and we were
talking about this little before it's
interesting they're showing off like
good 10 minute demo there but
unfortunately that kind of game really
is incredibly deep and there's really
not that much you can see in a short 10
minute demo and I think they're banking
on the assumption that when people are
playing this but they have some kind of
XCOM reference anyone who's ever played
XCOM typically loves that style of game
and they'll immediately pick up on the
controls it's incredibly Semel area
you're playing this turn-based style
where you're you're clicking how far of
the distance if you click a particular
distance then you get another action
whether it be some kind of fighting move
they have people who can do a 0 e they
have people who have potions so those
are more healer types but as you said
massege house ads this extra component
to it so in XCOM you'd always get
worried that you would lose somebody
that you loved during petal you probably
named them as your friend and then
you're super bummed when they die
well massive tells is a little bit more
morbid because it takes place over
lengthy amounts of time years and years
generations and so everyone you play
will essentially die what you're
actually doing is you're trying to
combine two people and make children out
of them and get these amazing he rose
through the generations so I think I
think it's going to be really
interesting to see where they go with it
after my very short demo I was just
really excited to see and play more and
I think you're absolutely right it's
going to take way more than a 10 minute
demo for me to understand this game it
is not a double fine game at all like
when you look at it I feel like I think
about Double Fine's being kind of cute
and very funny and massive challenges
not like that at all yeah when I think
of double fine i think story-driven i
think something that has amazing
characters that you can't get enough of
and massive chalice is is not that i
think you make your own story and the
characters are what you create I think
you will still get that wonderful
attachment to characters similar like
you do in those style of games but it's
quite different than a double fine game
that we are that we're probably familiar
with so I guess we'll have to see where
they go with it and and I'm looking
forward to seeing especially master
Giles and very curious to see where they
go from here and everyone who comes to
pax gets to try it out themselves so
that's a double cool for everybody yeah
absolutely wonderful fun double cool
done fine sweet thanks Justin thank you